this is a production of Cornell
University
our topic today is actually around what
a practitioner needs to understand with
regard to field safety and there's a
number of aspects to it that I want to
just highlight to really give this
subject a solid treatment I'd have to
spend a lot more time on each individual
aspect but I want to give you an
overview of the kinds of things you need
to think of and just really go for the
low-hanging fruit if you if you don't if
you're having a hard time getting your
arms around what is filled safety by the
time I'm done you should at least have a
good understanding of the things you
need to have on hand to make sure you're
going to be successful should this ever
come into question for you now when you
think about the intricacies of field
safety there's two components to it
right you can have filled hardness that
you're likely to fall on and get hurt or
you can have high traction which
oftentimes leads to what we call
non-contact injuries and you can get
knee and ankle injury so we're talking
about hardness that causing concussions
and fractures and tractions that are
knee and ankle injuries and of course
what I've done here is look around the
particular issue and say what are the
thing what are the aspects of that
hardness that involve the soil in the
grass what are the aspects of that
traction that involved the soil in the
grass and then you know the non-contact
football injury risk is one of the
things that we constantly will come back
to so we're worried about risk from a
perspective of hardness and traction and
for the purposes of my time with you
today I'm strictly going to talk about
surface hardness but I want you to
understand that there is a very
sophisticated aspect of safety with
regard to traction now in New York State
we have a law now that has been passed
to protect athletes at the Scholastic
level from dat further damages from
concussion there the law the concussion
management and awareness
act has now put into place a series of
steps and methods and procedures and
diagnosis education plans that then
govern how when an a concussion is
suspected how it's diagnosed what kinds
of treatments are provided how long you
have to be away from the sport this has
become a very very very important aspect
of athletics at the Scholastic level and
what's been fascinating to me is in this
entire act that I've read at length
there's virtually nothing about field
safety there's nothing about field
hardness it's really all about sort of
determining was a concussion happening
and you know what do you do with the
athlete nothing about was it caused by
some sort of malfeasance on the field so
I'm drawing your attention to this
particular act because i think it's not
going to be long that there's an aspect
of this act that's going to impact the
way we manage our field so just like the
child safe playing field act that is
governing whether we can use pesticides
or not that we can't use pesticides on
school grounds this concussion
management act right now it does not
have strict legislation regarding field
management but it could eventually now
there's a number of papers that have
looked at field in injury associated
with the field it's typically done by
medical professionals sports medicine
doctors sort of epidemiologist people
who study sort of spread of disease and
injury and things like that and a lot of
times it's related to surveillance
systems NCAA or high school athletics
has an injury surveillance system that
they look for where the injuries
occurred now the other aspect of this
that's very important is the field
quality and oftentimes there's a
disconnect between the injuries that are
reported and the quality of the field
now this particular study published in
the American Journal sports medicine in
2004 looked at 250
games over a five-year period in high
school sports they looked at natural
turf which they didn't characterize the
quality of that natural turf and field
turf which is a a particular brand of
synthetic infilled turf where you have
the fibers and the rubber now I don't
know that anything is specific and
there's some sort of controversy between
the field turf people and this study but
for now it's a good indication i use
this because it's a good indication of
the things that actually will and could
happen now you have total injuries
injury rate per team game you've got
substantial injury and severe injuries
so substantial injury is you miss a
couple of games severe injury is you
miss months maybe even the whole season
now if you look at the differences
between a natural turf system and a
synthetic turf system the first thing
you'll notice is that the synthetic turf
system has a higher percentage of total
injuries occurring on synthetic turf
however when you look a little more
closely you see that the severe injury
ratings on natural turf is much higher
than it is on synthetic turf so while
you get more common injuries on field
turf and they're primarily epidermal
rashes rug burns and some muscle strains
the concussions as we indicated a minute
ago is what we are focusing on here in
New York and maybe field hardness is
much more common on natural turf now
here's where the tricky part comes it's
entirely possible that these fields were
in terrible shape because one of the
things we know is if you've got grass
you're likely to have a more cushion
surface so there could be these fields
that they're playing on may have a
significant amount of bare ground
exposed which could lead to these
concussions so so just so that you
wonder all you know they like to worry
about one surface adil from a safety
perspective they eat each surface has
their concerns the concussions on the
natural field and the epidermal
abrasions on the field turf now why
would you all just a rug burn why is
that a problem well the rug burn is in
fact a serious wound
we're blood vessels can be exposed and
athletes that then go into sweaty
whirlpools or sweaty weight rooms or go
back into the locker room and start
touching things with an open wound the
potential for MRSA methicillin-resistant
staphylococcus aureus this sort of
lethal fatal disease that can happen to
people that can they can contract in
those situations is very common where
you get a lot of these rug burns so
basically the solution to that is not to
spray the field with disinfectant
because that's not the issue the issue
is to treat the wound keep it clean
hygiene is the primary way you avoid any
further problems from from this so just
an overview of because you get a lot of
question about natural synthetic it's an
overview of this issue okay so let's
look a little bit on synthetic turf
safety if we're just holding on
synthetic turf gonna spend most of my
time talking about natural turf but I
want to make a point here on synthetic
turf there's two additional health
concerns on synthetic turf you need to
be aware of one is that there's been a
long time concern about the presence of
chemicals in these products lead in the
paint that they're making lead in the
plastic that the synthetic turf is made
out of and also contaminants in the
rubber that makes up the infill but the
fact is the body of research done shows
done with this and a lot of it was done
by the New York State Department of
Environmental Conservation has done a
thorough review of this and you can go
to the Dec website and see that report
which is you know mostly very in-depth
than science that I barely have can
understand but the conclusion was that
there's minimal health effects related
to the chemicals used in the synthetic
turf process but the other one that's
real is the heat on an 80 to 85 degree
bright sunny day temperatures on the
synthetic turf system reached between
120 and 146 to put this in perspective
you can fry an egg at 152 so this kind
of safety is a serious problem ajan
you're playing on a summer day on a
synthetic turf field and someone gets
injured and then has to lay on that
field waiting for assistance
about five or ten minutes on a surface
that's 140 degrees will create first and
second degree burns of the skin if their
skin exposed so you want to be very
careful generally what we say is
synthetic turf in northern climates is
ideal for the shoulders of the season
the spring sports and the late fall
sports are good to play on these systems
when the grass is no longer growing but
when the grass starts growing in the
summer months and you know the heat is
building on there you best stay off of
them because water will decrease the
temperature but temperature increased
back up to 90 to 120 within 30 minutes
so the heat is a serious concern with
synthetic turf now when we're talking
about hardness and we're going to talk a
lot about hardness of these systems you
have to understand the way we look at
this basically if you look at this as a
head when it's dropped okay if the
surface is it is hard and not sort of
receiving of the data of the of the
weight the energy the downward energy is
then reverberate it back into the head
and this is where the damage can occur
however when you have a softer surface
right and you drop your head or fall on
the surface the energy in that dropping
is dispersed into the turf rather than
back into the head that leads to the
concussion so this is an example of how
a ground could cause a concussion now we
have very particular ways and
standardized methods ASTM standards for
how field hardness or surface hardness
is assessed now this was started many
many years ago in the 80s there was some
receipt research at Michigan State that
looked at how to determine feel hardness
and they borrowed some technology from
the pavement industry to see how firm
the payment is they used to drop
specified weight down from a known
height and measure hardness and then
they adapted turf scientists adapted
that particular method of measuring
surface hardness into turf which has
then led to the f355
standard and the eff 1936 standard that
basically tells you if you're going to
measure surface hardness this is the way
you have to do have that a consistent
way of doing it so that what the
measurements all mean the same and then
we ultimately report it and you'll hear
it oftentimes referred to as GMAX
testing now gmax testing assesses the
risk of life-threatening head injuries
it does not assess the risk of bone or
joint injuries which could occur but
right now we're focusing on head
injuries and so impact testing as a
concept is a weight is dropped onto the
surface and the shock of the impact is
measured as negative a cell acceleration
so you drop the hammer down this tube
this is a very sophisticated GMAX device
20 grand for something like this you
drop it and following the method and
then the rate at which it decelerates or
stops is an indication of how the energy
is transferred back into the head or the
hammer and then that is reported as
gravities and the G max is maximum
deceleration the higher the value the
harder the surface now there's two ways
of doing this the Clegg hammer was the
original way that was designed by the
turf scientist to sort of look at field
hardness now what's not been well
established in this country and I'll
show you some data from Australia in a
minute is can you correlate the drop of
this particular device to the risk of
head injury now a different device the G
max testing that follows the F 1936 uses
a 20-pound weight which may be more
simulating what a head would do and the
shape of it is concave like that so the
the Clegg is for the natural turf but
not well correlated you can't substitute
this for the G max and there's some
sense of there are people that are
trying to do it but you have to be very
careful so here's the two devices that
they use to measure this now again this
is only an accepted method for synthetic
turf and here's the setup this is the
twenty-thousand-dollar setup that you
get where you lift the hammer and then
the reason this is an accepted method is
it tells you did you drop the hammer
right is it moving at the right speed
there's a number of quality controls
that this system does that you can't
with the simpler Clegg hammer that I'll
show you in a second 20 pound missile
drop from two feet you drop it three
times and the second two readings are
average so the very specific way that
field hardness is tested now if you have
a synthetic turf how often should you
test it now first of all when you buy a
synthetic turf and it's new you want to
do it and establish a baseline because
if the contractor leaves the site and
leave you in the field that is already
too high and unsafe you have no recourse
so make sure first of all you get it in
the spec that the field has to be built
so that when a gmax test is done at the
end it reads a number this or lower
alright so in ffort certainly to
establish a baseline also to make sure
you got what you paid for and then
annually thereafter on heavily used feel
so you'd say heavily is filled right I
got synthetic turf yeah synthetic turf
wears out the infill moves for those of
you that play lacrosse on the synthetic
turf you know that the goal mouth is
constantly having the rubber pushed away
and the fibers degraded and you'll often
and almost always get a much higher
reading by the goal mouth then you will
away from the goal mouth because the
rubber compacts or wears away and
therefore the surface becomes harder so
annually on heavy use fields and then if
you have reports of a serious head
injury and the field is implicated go
route you know immediately find someone
in the private sector and there's a
number of people particularly dr. Hummel
at Hummel and company that can go and do
this gmax testing for you to create a
body of evidence that you may need in a
legal case now let's talk about natural
turf no one would argue
certainly being on natural turf on a
summer day would be preferable but
certainly a well-maintained grass field
can be safe or a well-maintained
synthetic field can be safe if you're
going to maintain a cool-season turf
field and you're worried about liability
and risk management as a school board
member in a local community here I am
concerned about that one place to start
is that there is an ASTM standard for
maintaining cool-season turf on athletic
fields it's F 2060 and this is a
document you should have you should
understand should have a basic knowledge
of you know what's in here and am i
following and doing my due diligence so
this is number one something you should
have and also in a more plain English
approach to what's involved in a say
field that you might give to coaches and
players and community members
administrators is something that the
sports turf managers have developed a
foundation for safer athletic fields has
a whole four or five page very in plain
English natural grass athletic fields
for safety and I have the website there
but you can go to st ma org and access
this document now when you get involved
in the legal end of this process you
have to sort of learn some jargon and
one of the most important parts words
and jargon and field safety to see how
involved you may be is the duty of care
a duty of care is a legal obligation on
an individual organization required are
they you here to a standard of
reasonable care reasonable care this
would be considered reasonable care so
get this learn this it's very generic it
ought to be something you can easily
commit to doing reasonable care or
performing any acts that could be could
foreseeably harm others right are you
leaving rocks exposed on the fields it
is the first element that must be
established to proceed with action and
negligence so let's imagine an athlete
is using your field and falls and hits
there
and there's no grass there and someone
realizes that person's concussed and
they are going to seek remediation for
the damage that might have been done to
that child or adult on that field the
first thing they're going to do when you
get a lawyer involved is their
negligence and negligence could then be
established if you weren't taking
reasonable care now let's look at
potential risks now this is from a
sippers of beard publication from the
late 90s this is a born of foremost
turfgrass scientists in the united
states drop the Clegg hammer on a number
of different surfaces all right where a
cement floor was as much as 14 hundred
G's a football outdoor for your
artificial 175 you know you don't think
about this but in tennis if you fall and
hit your head that can't be good
basketball court that's not going to be
good baseball natural turf Bermuda grass
field so you can see very hard to softer
what's not well understood and not well
established in this country is well how
does this correlate the head injury
they've got it for the G max testing
they don't have it for the Clegg hammer
yet now as we're talking about legal
things that's the kind of data that a
good lawyer is going to start pulling
out and so as a school district as a
member of the school board I am
constantly mindful of the management of
risk in a school district whether it's
how a teacher manages their classroom
it's how what kind of cleaning products
we use to clean the bathrooms to all the
way to how the fields are kept some from
a risk management perspective knowing
that field use with that wears out the
Centers of these fields often you can
see the wearing out here knowing that
that's one of the primary ways the turf
gets less safe is do we have enough
space for the amount of use that we have
is the space appropriate for the
type of use for example you know here's
a lacrosse field are they going to be
all right playing lacrosse on a little
bit of dirt skin here is it appropriate
for that use and is the space managed
properly do you have enough room is it
appropriate to play that sport there and
are you managing it properly so those
are the things I'm thinking about when
I'm thinking about moving further with
regard to this now one way to get your
arms around this is for communities led
by the groundskeeper with a board of
education or community sports people to
go out and assess the field now we
developed a tool many many years ago
that's very simple for the average
person to fill out if the grounds
managers there that grounds manager can
answer a question about whether it's the
field is watered how much fertilizer
they put on what the mowing height is
and that's it everything else can be
answered by a lay person that might use
the field and then you get a number by
answering these things so here is a
hectare soccer field where we rated
these numbers and it came out with a 31
and we're saying if you get between 21
and 35 you should reassess your
management program unless the quality
you expect is less than three but you've
got to wonder from a safety perspective
whether that field is at risk so if
you're over 35 you've got to think about
renovating those fields if you're under
21 you're doing pretty good so this this
Travis high school football is obviously
doing pretty good so an easy way to get
everybody on the same page and have a
conversation about the fields as you're
thinking about risk management now no
one's going to argue that a grass field
is really good when there's grass but in
fact there's data to support this
it starts out first of all by
understanding your soil this is the
amount of fine particles so when you go
from here you're probably talking about
a high sand content all the way up to a
really clay soil along the bottom here
and this is the hardness of that field
alright so when you dry that soil down
right you can see without any grass
cover without any grass cover as you add
more clay particles if you have a clay
soil field without any grass cover you
can see how hard it gets as it dries out
the more clay you add and then however
when you have a hundred percent grass
cover you can see that the grass
mitigates the hardness so what's the
message here well I'm trying to give you
really simple things the simplest thing
is if you have a natural grass field
make sure you've got vegetation i'm
going to say vegetation because we think
generally broadleaf weeds are not as
traffic tolerant we're still getting
some more data we've had some new data
from tennessee that's indicating they
don't hold up as well they wear out much
more quickly and that's a problem
because you want to have a grasp or
vegetated surface to mitigate the
hardness here especially for those of
you without irrigation as the fields
going to dry out more now I spent a
little time in Australia this past year
and traveled around looking at sports
fields and number of conversations with
the grounds industry over there and they
actually have guidelines that they've
developed from a number of studies
conducted in Australia on Australian
rules football fields because they play
Australian rules football which is this
sort of Gaelic football rugby soccer
thing it's they plan on a huge field
there's 17 guys on a side they're very
no equipment it's shorts and a t-shirt
that's it and they've actually developed
a system using the Klag which we in
right now in the states have not adopted
but
this is what they have done in Australia
where they're grading it as too low all
the way to unsafe okay so it's safe is
between 31 and 69 the preferred range is
between seventy and eighty nine now
they're also measuring this with related
related to traction as much as field
hardness that you could hit your head on
so that's probably why the preferable
range is good here and this is
considered unsafe because the traction
is probably really bad it's too soft so
you can have a field that's too soft and
you see that with muddy fields an ideal
field and a field that's too too hard
alright again we have not adopted this
but these are good values to just sort
of start with now if we can agree that
grass is good and just having this soil
covered is good then we've got to think
about how to maintain that cover because
overuse will result in failure so what
we want to do if that fail point is
usually you know over here we want to
move that fail point further over so
that the turf can sustain itself longer
and one of the things we've done with
this as some of our work with intense
over seating where we're over seating on
a weekly basis during the traffic period
light frequent amounts of seed thrown on
a regular basis to maintain turf cover
where normally the traffic would wear
out the turf to this so you're talking
about is this safer than this I can't
say specifically but in general we know
the more grass you have the safer that
field is going to be so here's the study
we did we took this field we motored at
three inches we traffic the equivalent
of five games between the 20 and between
the hash mark so lots of traffic there
was no water we watered we fertilize
twice a year we use the drop spreader
because the soil is exposed from the
traffic so you to get good soul see
contact under high traffic you don't
have to slip seed in fact several
studies have shown slits eating makes it
worse because since these
to dig things up and then you've got rye
grass bluegrass and tall fescue now
there's the only two pieces of data that
i'm going to show you we did this over a
three-year period and the rainfall
amount in the first year was twenty
percent below normal so here is the
treatment to 48 and or ten pounds of
seed per thousand this is turf density
twenty percent turf density which means
the grass is not very much eighty-five
percent means you have a lot more grass
and then in a dry year we density you
didn't see a big difference in the
amount of weeds that invaded because
there was no water for the weeds to grow
we looked at turf quality which I'm not
going to worry about and we look at G
max which I'm not necessarily going to
talk about but essentially you notice as
you go from twenty percent turf cover at
130g max down to eighty five percent
turf cover at 55 that the turf gets
softer now this was true for both
perennial ryegrass and for tall fescue
this did not work for Kentucky bluegrass
because it takes much longer for the
Kentucky bluegrass seed to Germany so
fast germinating plants like printer I
and tall fescue will work fine now the
second two years of the study the exact
same thing but we got regular rainfall
matter of fact above average rainfall
and what you see is what because of the
traffic without any feeding there's no
turf left lots of weeds no turf just a
little bit of feed two pounds per
thousand per week gave us eighty-five
percent gave us eighty-five percent turf
density and did a really good job of
controlling weeds turf quality was
excellent and field firmness or field
hardness was much lower so when you have
you know if you have you if there's
going to be rainfall you had the ability
irrigate as little as two pounds of seed
can be enough to turn a field from a
disaster into a safer field because I
can tell you if a kid gets hurt on a
field that looks like this they're going
to come after someone for reasonable
care
so let's look at this if you're looking
at an American football field you're
looking at between hash marks and
between the 20 yard lines that's where
eighty percent of the traffic in an
American football field occurs between
the 20s and between the hash marks
that's your eye traffic area let's go
through the economics people say oh my
god throw Sierra week I going to do that
well let's go to the two-pound rate per
thousand so let's say we're putting out
two pounds per thousand assume a doll 25
per pound some people can get a cheaper
so that's a weekly cost of two dollars
and fifty cents a thousand that area
between the 20s between the hash is
16,000 square feet so assuming these
seed rates cost of seed weekly cost per
thousand multiplied by the area that
you're going to treat it's forty dollars
a week for seed let's say you did it 13
weeks in the fall and 13 weeks in the
spring soccer or football in the fall
lacrosse in the spring that's 26 weeks
it'd be a thousand dollars in seed costs
so it's not a burden for most even small
school districts like mine could afford
a thousand dollars receipt now here's an
example of trial we did in the Albany
area dave chinner ER extension faculty
in the capital district has done a lot
of work with this repetitive over
seating and this is one of his trials
where they had played football played
football on it did the over seating and
then left it for the next year they
didn't do it again and you can see in
these plots where they over seated and
where they didn't where they didn't this
is loaded with crabgrass and where they
did there's very little weeds growing in
there at all so obviously there can be
some weed control associated with that
now another way to get a safe field
especially if you're you know really in
a pinch and have to get that field in
shape really quickly which what the
professional athletes do and there's a
shot at a professional stadium with the
installation of what we call thick cut
sod where normally SOG would be cut
between a half and three quarters of an
inch
here you're talking about an inch and a
half to two inches of soil underneath so
it's a very very heavy side so that when
you lay it you can play right on it
immediately because it won't move well
Peters oh how might we do that well
thick cut sod is roughly sixty cents a
square foot your goal mouth area that's
bear here is roughly ten by ten alright
sixty cents a square foot by a hundred
square foot goal mouth area sixty
dollars and you could do it a number of
times that it's always going to be safe
for those athletes there so many people
have started to consider this because we
know that having grass is the key the
first step to making that field safer
I'll turn your attention back to this
standard that this is the minimum that
you should be doing you got to get your
hands on this and understand what's
involved in it and then simply focus on
keeping the use to a level you can
manage and then try innovative things
like the regular / seem to keep that
grass in place because that natural turf
surface that has the grass on it is
always going to be a safer surface in
general than bare soil and then the
synthetic and natural turf debate is
going to continue with no real clear
answers until we get our arms around
exactly how we can use the clec values
in natural turf so I hope I gave you a
little bit of an overview of this
particular topic I know you're going to
have a lot more time to discuss this
over the course of the day and thanks
for the time
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu